well so so Peter I I'm a huge fan of
your work even before Doctor Who growing
up as a kid watching watching Neverwhere
and then seeing you become the doctor
has been such a such an exciting thing
and I know you're probably gonna get
this question a lot but this is probably
the first character that will have been
turned into a toy and figure in this and
despite having played lots of the iconic
characters I'd never wear in in Malcolm
this is the first one who I think
probably fits that the best what's it
been like being a figure a cartoon in a
strange because first of all it's so
amazing to have the role in the first
place you can't quite believe your luck
that they're letting you be Doctor Who
but you never really quite believed it
until they actually present you with a
figure more in this sense of a LEGO
version of yourself you think oh it must
actually be happening it's for real
because that does look like me although
I'm almost slightly short seem to have
gray hair but I didn't seem to there act
when I started but I do not but it looks
great on the figure yeah it's amazing I
mean it's just the UM the scale of
Doctor Who is just much bigger than
anything else that I've worked on and
like most shows of its nature there's
this balance that you have to strike
between making the program and sillier
but you have to face the reality that
you know people want toys and they want
books and things as I did when I was a
little kid but when I was a little kid
the Doctor Who merchandise was basically
there was one book that came out every
year which is the Doctor Who annual and
maybe a little TARDIS thing or a little
Dalek occasionally now there's as fast
you know toy store full of stuff but
yeah it's very exciting to see yourself
portrayed in that way although you have
to let your vanity go out the window is
it is it humbling to see a figure of
yourself and then to see yourself
directly oh absolutely because also it
is you know the
the thing that people are responding to
is dr. hurts on me you know and Matt
will say the same and David and Chris's
you find yourself you you wear this
mantle of doctor but the thing that
people are crazy about this Doctor Who
it's not it's not the actor but you get
the benefit of their affection for all
the doctors and you see it in game form
was so exciting because to be honest I
wasn't quite sure what it was going to
be when the guy started talking to me
about it and because I'm not all favor
that world terribly but I was knocked
out I thought this had a scale at a kind
of movie kind of a sense about it
officially I just thought this is
dazzling you know and and the great
thing about the whole lego world and the
way that it's been expanded into games
and movies and stuff is it comes with an
irony and a wit but not to the cost of
the essence of the of the characters you
know Doctor Who is still a
time-traveling Dalek fighting rebel Time
Lord but I think there's a little bit of
it as aware that he's a Lego figure that
gives them a kind of sense of irony and
the whole games like that it's very very
exciting
so yeah it's not something it's not even
something I would ever have imagined
uh or even could have imagined I
wouldn't know how it would look but all
the figures look amazing or Gandalf lets
a ton of the Daleks I love the little
Daleks and I mean which actually are
still quite scary when you see them over
the voice Nick Briggs doing the voice
and all that it's great what did you
expect when you we're told you're gonna
be in a video game you're gonna be
playing the video game cares you know
half the time I don't know what they
were talking about just a nod but
knowing you know yeah that sounds great
hot sauce
okay oh no no no what this is gonna be
like it's just another thing you think
because we're again when you become
doctor who suddenly there are hundreds
of different games / books outlets and
social media things above us suddenly
you're not just playing a part you have
to deal with all this other stuff so I
wasn't really quite sure it took me a
while to make the connection between leg
over the figures and a video game but in
fact that you can bring these two things
together in such a exciting way was a
revelation I sort of I guess didn't
realize that the game would be so epic
and so engaging I sort of thought that
there would be a just a bit he would
always be saying oh it's you know least
someone going like this but in fact it's
it's so entertaining I didn't realize
that that'd be so much wet in the
dialogue and in there and then the
relationships between the characters
they're very full and very amusing so
that was really an eye-opener to me
people in many video games yourself is
this one of the first I'm gonna say no
but I you know I'm very I'm very
ignorant of it oh really yeah so that's
why my eyes would glaze over as people
were talking to me now and I would say
yeah yeah that's that's fun that sighs
I've never really quite knowing what to
expect but no it's not really part of my
world or part of my experience that said
you know I haven't seen this I'd love to
buy it not just because I because I'm in
act but because it's it's a whole
entertainment that I didn't sort of
realize was there that such like I've
been in the jungle didn't realize the
war was over
come on give us television and stuff but
yeah I thought it was remarkable and so
much of Doctor Who is is what you bring
to the character but it's also the
writing though and what the writers have
crafted around that is it does that feel
like it's a part of this this M as well
absolutely
don't think it would be as much fun if
it was not as Whittier is thought
through as if it was not if there was a
plot that was this but is this in a
villain like this you know all of that
stuff is meat you know that makes it
interesting that makes it fun I'm very
keen with Doctor Who that Tom we work
very very hard to try and make the show
that the best that we can and sometimes
we have limitations of time and budget
you know and one of the reasons Doctor
Who looks so great is because a lot of
fans work on the show and so sometimes a
lot of the time people do stuff that
they are not really getting paid for or
that they because it is Doctor Who they
want to go the extra mile with so it's
very important we're involved with any
merchandising and stuff that it is of a
similar imaginative ambition and I think
that's undoubtedly that's true true of
this this game you know it's it's you
know it's exciting it's if it's Daleks
Cybermen the Dalek Emperor and the
voices it's you know it's all going on
you know you're not getting shortchanged
which is fantastic it's something that
draws a so many fans and you you have I
think a lot of successes in in cold hits
even even here in America like you're
definitely you were a known person
before you did Doctor Who but that's
just exploded your popularity and now
coming to comic-con like that so that's
gonna be a different experience than
than anything you yeah having for what's
then grow that explosion bed like well
first of all I've never been to
comic-con before so I really only I go
onto the internet and look at pictures
of a previous comic console Emma
absolutely enthralled and charmed by all
these photos of people in costumes of
varying degrees of professionalism and
that's what's cool I quite like about I
like the least professional ones I think
of my favorite ones because I think
they're the dumbest such humorous
applause I think it's the you know I've
had to confront the fact that my I am
more well known and more visible face
but I think I'm very lucky in the fact
that I play Doctor Who so what happens
to me is I get the affection exposed to
the affection that people have for the
show which you think is a rather more
welcomed thing than if you were just
famous for being an actor in a show
because it's this very special show and
then you become they you carry the
mantle of it for whatever period you're
playing it you get the benefit of the
work that everybody else is done on and
so yes it's been strange I mean I I
realize I have to be careful what I say
and all that I never liked it to say I
think particularly bad or whatever but
you know I realize I'm having chatting
to people and somebody's got a ball bar
for and going and they're filming me and
stuff for that I think I can't possibly
be saying I think any interest to anyone
but um that's just the way of the world
but I would say generally the the
affection with which people greet Doctor
Who is a great thing to have in your
life and that only I mean sometimes I
just talked to Matt or to David about it
you know and it's extraordinary very few
of us have been in this position this
great one to be in if you haven't before
I'm sure at this point you're you're
going to meet people who are dressed up
as you know something you you've met
before are you expecting your sons when
we go on location you know a little bit
of a smattering of people sometimes
someone comes and says I'm dressed as
Europe with an unrecognizable
which they've God was gonna but I always
submit in a way it's weird because I
never really when I chose what I was
going to wear as Doctor Who I've never
had any thought in mind about people
dressing up in fact quite the contrary I
thought it was important to just try and
get what what made me feel like Doctor
Who and I didn't want to have something
that had things that were could be
fastened on to and easily well I wanted
something that could be easily copied
because I thought I wanted kids to be
able if they wanted to just have their
school shot and just bun up and they'd
have a doctor who shot and just wear a
dark jacket whatever so I wanted
something very very simple but um I
didn't realize that was it then in
itself become a kind of little icon and
so now I can see people approach me in
the dress that they're in and the black
or the Doppler with the Reds and that
looks quite good so we serve
accidentally stumbled upon something
that it looks at quite good I think it
is you know it's someone who hasn't
played video games with maybe sees them
as something that that could be fun dude
do you see that as a positive this
melding of worlds of fan fandom like
Doctor Who and video games and I see it
as a positive if it's done to this
quality you know because the demands and
ambition that the the game makers have
imposed upon themselves are very high
you know they've given themself the task
of creating something that's very
entertaining very exciting and dramatic
so I think as long as we are trying to
make good material to a high standard it
is good you know if we're just going to
use these characters as as marketing
devices for for no particularly false
or exciting eye games then no but that's
not where we are I think that's that's
the really exciting thing is that if the
characters are existing in another
hugely dramatic fun and witty world and
it's just a bonus really to what we're
already doing